i
[Música]
ah
cristiano ronaldo no ha podido
reincorporarse a las canchas tras
resultar normalmente positivo a kobe 19
por lo pronto no podrá participar en el
encuentro contra el barcelona el próximo
28 de octubre como parte de la segunda
jornada de la champions league sin
embargo para la juventus no todo está
perdido aseguran que en los últimos
exámenes que se le practicaron al
jugador la carga viral es muy baja por
lo que van a solicitar nuevamente la
uefa antes 48 horas antes del partido a
la espera de que el resultado sea
negativo y por supuesto será la uefa
quien tenga la última palabra mientras
tanto cristiano ronaldo se mantiene en
su residencia en turín italia se ha
visto bastante activo a través de las
redes sociales e incluso ha publicado
vídeos ejercitándose se encuentra
asintomático así lo está desde la
primera vez que resultado positivo a
kobe 19 recordemos esto fue el pasado 13
de octubre cuando se encontraba en
portugal junto a la selección en el
complejo deportivo ciudad de fútbol al
día siguiente el jugador portugués
decidió partir a italia para ya
continuar con la cuarentena y
practicarse nuevos exámenes
[Música]
son muchos los jugadores brasileños que
ya han contraído el cob y 19 el más
famoso sin dudas es neymar el delantero
del parís saint german que a principios
de septiembre dio positivo al test de el
coronavirus sin embargo se recuperó
rápidamente después de sus vacaciones a
la isla de ibiza y volvió a las canchas
el 12 de septiembre ya en brasil tras
disputar un partido en ecuador 16
jugadores del club flamengo fueron
contagiados pero el dato global es
asustador a día de hoy 30 de los 33
jugadores del club más popular de brasil
han tenido el coronavirus ya a nivel
nacional los datos también preocupan la
confederación brasileña de fútbol
contabilizaba al final de septiembre 182
jugadores con el virus de casi 10.000
tests realizados este alto número de
contagios mantiene viva la polémica
sobre la seguridad de jugadores y
empleados en el mundo del fútbol
[Música]
los casos de kobe 19 en deportistas
franceses remontan a marzo con el
positivo de blesa madrid y jugador de la
juventus de turín después del
confinamiento de los casos volvieron a
resurgir esta vez en el mundo de los
rugby en el campeonato francés en el que
al menos siete equipos tenían jugadores
que habían dado positivo de hecho el
estadio 'josé que es uno de los clubes
pues no pudo alinear absolutamente
ningún jugador en al menos tres
ocasiones varios de ellos con lesiones
pulmonares a finales de octubre fue el
turno para bueno ap a quien dio positivo
porque hoy 19 y fue excluido del abierto
de tenis de estados unidos tres de sus
compañeros además tuvieron que ser
puestos en cuarentena luego el virus
llegó hasta los bestiarios del parís
saint germain septiembre 9 jugadores
dieron positivo uno de ellos querían
papel la estrella del equipo y también
de la selección francesa y en los
últimos casos deben venir a engrosar
esta larga lista pues es el de nace
abuani pedalista de ar que assange y que
quien esta semana tuvo que retirarse de
la carrera entre brujas y la pana
[Música]